I want to hear from you on this draft
day on which CD lamken will be become a
member of a team in the National
Football League and he has been kind
enough to join us here on behalf of Old
Spice here on the Rich Eisen show good
to chat with you CD lamb how are you sir
the butterflies flying in your stomach
right now
how do you feeling yeah is it a zoo a
meeting in there they zooming in just
like even how many teams have you spoken
to okay and what are they what do they
basically want to know from you just
personal off the field and all over your
table what do you what do you bring to
the table
great competitiveness teaching a team
and homology huh I'm respect and Debbie
take my job seriously and I can't wait
for an opportunity now CD if you if you
are you know drafted as high as people
expect you to be drafted tonight and you
have a shorter night potentially than
then than others what will it mean to
you what will it mean to you when you
finally have that dream come true and
you get a phone call tonight and you're
in the NFL what will that mean
it will mean a lot to you in the book
the world itself there's nothing I can I
can I'm able to held up to me to play
with the best of the best you know also
just just all the work that I've been
doing before pre-draft and just do dr.
cha process and even before that out of
your high school middle school are they
used to us but I would join all that
it's kind of paying off for me to be as
good as I am right now I know it's
definitely a great feeling the feeling
when you've been to a lot of work and a
lot of tough times so so how tough were
the times for those who may not know
your story city moves and family members
to form again shake your family breaking
language it's a lot that ties into it
and I'll just
just stand hungry and just keeping the
same magic drive throughout it all I
said is these value my money and I feel
like I'm gonna great job
well who's helped you stay grounded
who's helped you keep your head screwed
on right so you have this opportunity in
the NFL tonight walk me through a lot of
people could tell me that you know it's
not good for me to be here that's right
I've done a great job just listening to
myself and all the outside people all
the people that told me you know and
just gather trouble and all that which
I've done a great job of doing and
that's this point is you do rewarding I
can't wait to feel the the whole deal
and you're from the great state of
Louisiana is where you were born correct
so how did you get to Oklahoma City
football and football last year see
obviously it Texas football is like
definitely enhanced but just kind of
going just going from Louisiana to
Houston which is good and just good
enough my family and just kind of stand
ground to stand on the right path and
keeping the same mindset draw all my my
my ages of life and I can bless men and
that's I've been doing up to this point
thinking guy giving him all the praises
but I don't get that bad and just being
myself every day is it true that your
family relocated to Houston because of
Hurricane Katrina that's how you wound
up in the state of Texas cdma2000 2008 I
think ok night again just because to me
draft nights are about journey's CD I
mean I could sit here and ask you about
you know your football abilities we've
seen that with our own two eyes it
really is about what beats inside and
how you have how you have handled your
business and overcome obstacles to get
to this point what are your memories of
Katrina how
were you do you remember that
essentially you're their CD you're
blocking your phone okay see you
definitely have some memories of that
[Music]
going all over the place
branches flying all over the place it
was a very scary moment and I honestly
for a moment just not wanting to be a
part of it anymore want to get out
wishing everything was fine and at that
point tonight I took life for granted
before just not enjoying even at a young
age I knew like I'd enjoy every buck use
me every moment but is that any day it
could be our ticket away from me and
then that's kind of this Katrina said it
off for me and then give me anywhere
thinking I can she doesn't hate I was
about ten years old so a two-year
differencing boom you get here with
another one or two three year difference
in it it's just it's just like wow I
cannot run away from these things right
we're going on honey following there's a
lot of questions that you get and then
you get to Oklahoma and man or do you
play with some fast fantastic
quarterbacks I mean fantastic
quarterbacks that you play with one of
whom apparently has been pounding the
table for their team to select you in
the top ten what conversations have you
had with Kyle Emery of late CD just been
receiver that they favorite target you
know kind understanding they're
different different types of
quarterbacks like place thousands these
guys what they're comfortable and there
was a knock on circle and she's kind of
trying to build on what their strong
TSA's and just trying to connect along
to one another okay see deal am here on
behalf of Old Spice which is fans can
making contributions of their own just
like Old Spice is going to be donating
$320,000 to the United Way on behalf of
CD and rookies from all 32 teams
to help young players begin their
charitable efforts as soon as they join
the league I look forward to watching
you get drafted tonight CD walk me
through who you're gonna be with this
evening when you get that phone call and
you get this made official this evening
family I'm a girl gun ban agenda for
sure but I'm just going for this
opportunity and I can't wait to fulfill
this dream that I've been thinking about
for every reason to be here now actually
CD you take care of yourself thanks for
the time good luck tonight and and we'll
be chatting once you're on the other
side of this and then you're in the NFL
and I'd love to have you as a regular on
this show I appreciate things you got
that CD lamb hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here